son vivant un sucré c'est bon ça peut
faire sourire des insectes dans
l'assiette mais il se pourrait que ce
soit le futur de l'alimentation ces
petites bébêtes sont bourrés de
protéines de vitamines mais l'idée d'en
manger n'a rien de nouveau
déjà en 1959 des membres de l'ocf
l'envisagé comme la gastronomie du futur
voici leurs documents mu est doublé par
nos soins on va dire aujourd'hui à
régner sur canapé sandwichs aux
chenilles et tourte aux larves de tan
tan je vais prendre la même chose que
monsieur les insectes non pas pour
autant gagné nos cuisines au mieux
certaines boutiques aujourd'hui
proposent des insectes apéritif de type
grillon à l'ail
mais là non plus rien de bien neuf il y
en avait déjà en 1971 dans une épicerie
fine parisienne vous avez des chenilles
qui sont grillés légèrement salée vous
avez également à côté des sauterelles
chocolat à vrai dire les un sceptre en
partie de l'alimentation de l'humanité
depuis toujours c'est resté dans
certaines cultures
mais en france c'est plutôt un élément
de curiosités comme la télé des années
90 les aînés jeune homme avoue cavayère
courageux son vivant un sucré c'est bon
c'est sucré c'est bon la télé c'est en
rire mais dans cette même émission
un chercheur nous expliquait aussi
pourquoi croquer des insectes
non merci la réflexion est purement
psychologiques et culturels
on nous a appris depuis tout petit les
insectes c'est sale alors qu'en fait les
insectes sont beaucoup plus propres que
des mous des huîtres qui vont être les
filtres de la mer en europe la vente
d'insectes comestibles et encadrée
depuis 2018 des marques ont ainsi
développé leurs insectes apéro conçu des
steaks d'insectes et des restaurateurs
ont travaillé les bébêtes dans des
recettes de la devenir une alternative à
la viande ce n'est pas encore ça
[Musique]